from a musical hijacking to unpacking
chicks past it's time to wrestle with
all the drama on Sweetwater secrets
[Music]
welcome back river babes
I'm your host Leonid Galera and this is
the Sweetwater secrets after-show for
Episode two eleven chapter 24 the
wrestler now you guys know how much I
absolutely adore Riverdale but I'm not
gonna lie this was not my favorite
episode in my opinion it was full of
frustrating moments and awkward
alliterations the general Pickens who
statue stands proudly in Pickens Park
but nevertheless I'll be breaking down
the biggest moments of the week and
gifting you with my long list of hisses
and only one single kiss so let's take a
look at the top headlines of the week in
the blue and gold breakdown first up the
super shady FBI agent ordered Archie to
get on Hiram's good side so at
Veronica's suggestion Archie decided to
skip basketball tryouts and try out
something new wrestling really turns out
Hiram was a star wrestler back in his
day at Riverdale high and the entire
episode was one big who has more pent-up
testosterone competition in the end
Archie and Hyrum ended up in a
semi-decent place but honestly by then I
was totally over it
moving on to Pickens day drama it's
clear that Jughead was on the hunt to be
pissed about something new this week so
he decided to be outraged about the
history of one of Riverdale's oldest
celebrations
now after thoroughly upsetting Tony
Jughead tried to make good by arranging
a protest at the festival unfortunately
Hiram charmed his way through the
disruption and nothing really changed
well except for the statue of general
Pickens and lastly things in the Cooper
household got even more bizarre thanks
to Kevin we finally found out what
chick's job is he's a video gigolo on a
webcam boy a cyber traitor but instead
of being shocked Betty realized that she
wanted to be part of the web cam
craziness
something tells me this isn't going to
end well
but that's a story for another episode
moving on
to seven seconds in heaven alright guys
this episode was pretty light on the
romance now aside from Betty's quick
jealousy eyes when she guessed jugheads
after-school plans
fans were Tony yeah sings on the bug
head front remain non-existent as for
var Qi News
Veronica is proving to be quite the
little manipulator now lately she's been
batting her lashes and gifting Archie
with kisses only when she wants to
convince him to do something for her and
when she doesn't have any requests she's
brushing off her BAE with pretty shallow
excuses I just hated your sweaty wasn't
up Vee you know I adore you but you're
starting to become quite the Shady Lady
which leads us straight into our hisses
and kisses
all right guys first up hisses go to
Veronica for her haughty behavior and
for straight-up stealing from Josie
Veronica and the Pussycats
and aside from Josie's crushed face it
seems like Kevin is the only other
person who realized how messed up this
musical hijacking was hisses to the
entire wrestling storyline come on I
can't I just can't and his is to check
for getting me the chills
look chickadee I don't care if you tried
to explain why you were looking at your
sister in the dead of night I still
think you're creepy as hell and I don't
trust you at all it's okay it doesn't
bother me this is to hell for being the
second most frustrating member of the
Cooper family it's now more than obvious
that chick must be FP son and that's why
Hal hates him so much also am I the only
one who sees that there are two extra
chairs at the Cooper table I have no
idea why there was such a fuss over the
seating chart do you know who used to
sit there this is - Penelope blossom for
trying to seduce Hal now I'm not an
expert in genetics but I'm pretty sure
that Penelope and Hal are somehow
related at the very least she's hitting
on her dead husband's cousin you know
this is to Betty for always dismissing
Kevin like a second-class friend
yeah Kyle and his sister Jughead for
once again throwing himself into the
drama we get it juggy your broody and
moody but I'd rather see you put that
energy into getting your friendship back
on track with Archie have they even said
two words to each other since being back
at the same school I don't think so my
one and only kiss of the episode goes to
Cheryl for standing up against her
family and putting her allegiance in the
right place plus we're getting closer
and closer to making Shoni happen people
yes ladies all right guys now that does
it for this weeks after-show rants but
now I want to hear from you were you as
disappointed by the wrestler as I was
and who else thinks that Veronica is
getting a little too shady is chick
ruffle in your feathers share your
hisses and kisses with me in the
comments below or chat with me on
Twitter and please give this video a
like and be sure to subscribe to et's
youtube channel so you never miss an
episode of Sweetwater secrets until next
time river babes
[Music]
you